What is the P value? We can't use the T table. We can use the T table for an
interval estimate for our P value but we can't use it to find the exact P
value. Since our sample has 8 values, we have 7 degrees of freedom. And out T
statistic is in between 0.896 and 1.119. That means the upper tail of our P
value would be between 0.15 and 0.20. And so, at the lower tail of our p value
which means that our total p value would be between 0.3 0.15 plus 0.15, and
0.4. 0.2 plus 0.2. But we don't need to be able to do it by hand or with a
table. Because these days, we can use software. There's a website called graph
pad. The link is below. And use that to calculate what this p value is, and you
should find that it's between 0.3 and 0.4. Navigate to statistical
distributions and interpreting p-values, and then based on the fact that we're
doing a two-tailed test, and we know our t-test statistic, figure out the rest.
What did you get for the two-tailed p value? Is this statistically significant,
or not statistically significant? And that's because of which of these options.
Therefore, what's our decision?